the 30-day declutter is the core of my
philosophy of digital minimalism my
approach to it was it can't start with a
habits in the tactics you can't start
with like let me get right to studying
filters and turning off notifications
and not having my phone in my bedroom if
that doesn't work you're going to end up
back where you were digital minimalism
by contrast was this humanist philosophy
where it says no you got to figure out
what you're all about like what you
really care about and what you want to
do and then work backwards and say what
heck supports that and that's how you
choose what pack you use in your
personal life and what rules you put
around it that's much more sustainable
but how do you figure out this question
like how do you get that insight into
what do I really want to do what's
important to me when you already have
all that distraction that's for the
declutter and so I said take 30 days
where you don't use social media you
don't stream online videos no video
games no online news that's very
influenced by you and your low
information diet for example and you
experiment and you reflect and you think
about life and go for walks and join
things and ride your bike and hang out
with friends without sending them
messages on a blowing app screen and you
figure out what you're all about and
then at the end of the 30 days you say
what do I want to